about a year ago Sports Illustrated
uploaded a video to their various social
media channels it which shows Steph
Curry the Golden State Warriors point
guard in NBA champion uh making five
full-court shots in a row just about 30
seconds now in case you're not familiar
with basketball this is an athletic feat
that is about as close to to
statistically impossible as you can get
but Sports Illustrated played it
straight uh the outlet wrote on their
Twitter account quote just finished a
shoot with Steph Curry this dude just
can't miss
now watching it there's no obvious way
to tell that it's fake even if you watch
it a few times it seems real you see him
shoot the basketball the camera follows
the ball goes in the hoop looks
basically legitimate but of course none
of it was legitimate and Sports
Illustrated knew that because the
creator of this clip who they tagged in
one of the posts is known for
manipulating videos like this one the
whole thing was basically just a bid for
some attention on social media and
there's the clip now nobody really
followed up on on this whole episode
there was no ensuing conversation about
ethics and sports journalism when Sports
Illustrated ultimately admitted that it
was a sham nobody cared and on one level
that's not especially surprising since
Sports Illustrated is a shadow of what
it once was other than the annual
swimsuit edition which presumably Now
features trans and plus-size models and
all the rest of it uh there's no longer
anything to distinguish the magazine
from any number of other lowquality
sports blogs you can find all over the
Internet that's been true for quite some
time but what's what's interesting about
this episode is what happened afterwards
Sports Illustrated didn't stop lying to
its audience after this they didn't
decide to renew their commitment to
serious sports journalism to the extent
that serious sports journalism isn't an
oxymoron instead Sports Illustrated
chose to start faking a lot more than
just videos a website called
futurism just published an investigative
report in to the scam that Sports
Illustrated has been running and
apparently the company has been using
artificial intelligence to draft uh not
just little videos like this but entire
articles and more than that they've been
using AI to create fake authors as well
complete with fake biographies the
outlet never disclosed any of this to
its readers obviously so here for
example is their biography of uh
somebody named Drew Ortiz who appears to
be a white male with brown hair and blue
eyes looks kind of like a normal guy
this is straight from Sports
illustrated's website says quote Drew
has spent much of his life outdoors and
is excited to guide you through his
NeverEnding list of the best products to
keep you from falling to The Perils of
nature nowadays there's rarely a weekend
that goes by where Drew isn't out
camping hiking or just back on his
parents
Farm now obviously most of the
biographies that you read online are
stilted and fake like this but even by
that low standard Drew Ortiz's bio is a
little
suspect what does it mean to keep you
from falling to The Perils of nature
exactly it sounds a little bit morbid
and once you find out that AI was
responsible for it the Perils of nature
line starts to seem more than a little
bit creepy but you're not supposed to
dwell on Drew's biography instead you're
supposed to click on his articles
because that's how Sports Illustrated
makes money and once you do that once
you click the AI generated clickbait uh
here's what you'll find one of Ortiz's
articles which was originally published
last year is entitled play like a pro
with the best full-size volleyballs and
the point of this article is to
advertise a series of volleyballs so
that Sports illustrat can get a kickback
when people click on the links and buy
volleyballs which is pretty standard in
digital media as you probably have
noticed the Drew Ortiz artificial
intelligence for its part was tasked
with writing a paragraph to introduce
all of these affiliate links
and here's what Drew came up with uh
here's what the AI came up with for one
of the volleyballs quote volleyball is
one of the most popular sports in the
world and for good reason it's
fast-paced has a high skill ceiling and
is generally an exciting sport to both
play and watch even people who don't
watch sports can easily understand the
intensity and skill required to play
volleyball whenever they watch Clips
there's a reason why it's been such a
Mainstay in modern sports to this day
volleyball can be a little tricky to get
into especially without an actual ball
to practice with now up until that last
line you could see why somebody might be
fooled into thinking that Drew Ortiz is
a real person he comes across as maybe
an Earnest guy just trying to explain
why he loves volleyball in as many words
as possible but towards the end Drew
enters the uncanny valley by saying that
volleyball can be a little tricky to get
into especially without an actual ball
to
practice well that's kind of an
understatement Drew it's it's a bit like
saying water polo is hard to get into
without water or cooking is hard to do
without food it's the kind of thing that
no human being would ever actually say
so needless to say the AI known as Drew
Ortiz wasn't exactly producing the most
compelling copy we can assume that very
few people bought volleyballs on Drew's
professional recommendation and that
could be why sometime this summer Sports
Illustrated quietly replaced Ortiz with
another Ai and this time the name for
the AI changed from Drew Ortiz to Sora
Tanaka who is Sora Tanaka well let's see
according to her biography on Sports
Illustrated website quote Sora has
always been a fitness Guru and loves to
try different foods and drinks she is
fond of varying her workouts and
believes that everyone should
participate in some form of physical or
mental activity at least three times per
week I just to read that last part again
she believes everyone should participate
in some sort of physical or mental
activity at least three times per week
so talk about the soft bigotry of low
expectations we can infer from this that
AI doesn't exactly have a high opinion
of humans if this is the bar it's
setting for us just use your body or
your mind three times a week is
all let's let's just start there AI is
saying to the human race and I'd like to
say I'd like to think anyway that robots
are underestimating us here but I don't
think that they that they are most
likely at this point it's important to
mention that Sports Illustrated didn't
just have ai generated articles
and fake biographies and fake writers
they also generated fake head shots for
these writers they generated images out
of thin air for people who don't exist
and who they were claiming were writing
articles that were not written by any
human at all both Tanaka and Ortiz had
uh these AI produced head shots and we
know that because the headshots were
available for sale on an online
Marketplace that sells AI head shots
because uh that's something that exists
now apparently and eventually after they
were confronted by futurism Sports
Illustrated took all these articles down
and the head shots down and they
scrubbed it all from their website now
in a statement the company blamed a
contractor for all this they denied that
the Articles were written by AI although
they didn't deny that the head shots
were AI generated so I guess they're
claiming that there were real people who
wrote the articles but they made up fake
people to say wrote them I don't exactly
understand that they also claim that
editors carefully review all the cont
content that's uploaded and that's a
claim that several other websites and
media Outlets have made in the past when
similar things have surfaced about them
CET for example insisted that uh while
it was using AI to draft articles
editors were carefully factchecking
every detail prior to publication well
how did that work out a few months ago
CET published an article claiming that a
$10,000 deposit in a savings account
earning a 3% apy would would return
10,000 $300 in profit after the first
year which you don't have to be a math
Wiz to know that's off by about
$110,000 CET later appended a correction
to the article uh somehow this slipped
by the fact Checkers I don't know bank
rate one of CET sister s sites has had
the same problem uh they claim that
their editors carefully review AI
generated articles but these articles
are full of mistakes as well including
mathematical mistakes which is which is
the one thing you would think AI would
always get right but apparently they
don't you know using the internet
without expressvpn it's like walking
your dog in public without securing him
on a leash most of the time you'll
probably be fine but what if one day
your dog runs away or gets dognapped
well it's better to be careful
especially when it's as simple as using
expressvpn every time you connect to an
unencrypted Network in cafes hotels or
airports Etc your online data is not
secure any hacker on the same network
can gain access to and steal your
personal data expressvpn creates a
secure encrypted tunnel between your
device and the internet so they can't
steal your data expressvpn works on all
your devices such as your phone laptop
tablet and even on your smart TV I love
how easy expressvpn is to use just fire
up the app and click one button to get
protected your data is your business
visit expressvpn.com
Walsh show use my Link at expressvpn.com
walow to get three extra months free
that's exp rsvpn
domcom Walsh show so what do we make of
all this
you know it's easy to mock Outlets like
CNET and bank rate whatever that is and
Sports Illustrated which nobody reads
anymore but it's not hard to see where
this is all heading I mean we are
rapidly and willfully moving towards a
dystopian world where AI does everything
and most human effort and labor has
become
redundant everyone can see this coming
and they know that it's bad but of
course it seems like our our leaders
none of them have the for ude to do
anything about it and AI replacing
Sports Illustrated writers is the least
of our concerns in this regard what
happens when AI starts replacing oh I
don't know truck drivers and uh rid
share drivers these are jobs that a
significant portion of the American
middle class depend on in order to
survive what happens when weo and Cruz
and Tesla manage to perfect their
self-driving AI what happens then and
we're not there yet of course uh it'll
likely be several more years until AI is
capable of doing any of that and it's
still possible we'll eventually elect
leaders in time who will do something to
prevent the potential destruction of
millions of jobs in this country all at
once which is where this is headed in
the meantime it's it's important to look
closely at the jobs that AI is capable
of replacing right now and what that
says about these jobs and our culture at
large at the moment you know it's hard
to deny that journalism and sports
journalism in particular has become so
vacuous and so pointless that it can
easily be replaced by robots and most
readers don't even
notice it's generally not a good thing
to replace human jobs with AI I'm
generally opposed to it but in the media
the point is that so many of the humans
doing these jobs are already barely
human as it is so it feels more like a
like a lateral move and this isn't just
happening at Sports Illustrated and CNET
and bank rate it's happening at all the
various tiers of garbage journalism
including gaming journalism the website
Kotaku uh Now features a few AI written
articles Microsoft start which is the
homepage that Microsoft presents to you
to uh users of its internet browser
recently featured an obituary with this
headline Brandon Hunter useless at
42 now this is a former NBA player who
died suddenly and that's the headline
that the AI went with he's not dead he's
quote
useless which is is sort of true in a
literal sense I suppose but that's not
how humans typically look at death uh
and you would hope that we wouldn't look
at it that way but Microsoft maybe the
biggest tech company on the planet
promoted that story and here's the
amazing thing it didn't cause any kind
of stir at all you probably didn't even
hear about it and that's because we're
used to this we take it for granted that
whatever garbage we read was either
written by a poorly programmed AI or it
was written by some liberal Arts
graduate with no life skills either way
we don't take it seriously it's just
noise the bar is so low that it's
impossible to be outraged by uh by any
of this indeed it's hard to be outraged
by the quality of pretty much anything
mass produced uh at this point
especially produced for Mass consumption
take popular music for example a few
days ago an AI singer songwriter using
the name Anna Indiana went viral on
social media with a a a song that this
AI produced uced and here's how Anna
Indiana introduced herself and followed
by uh the song
listen hello world my name is Anna
Indiana and I'm so excited to share my
music with you here's my first song
betrayed by this town as an AI singer
songwriter everything from the key Tempo
chord progression Melody notes Rhythm
lyrics and my image and singing is
autogenerated using a I I hope you like
[Music]
it sitting at my favorite Cafe sipping
my tea it's Saturday thinking about all
he's done to it
everyone this town is full of Broken
Dreams shattered hopes and Silent
screams somebody please
help
me the trade by this
town let's tear it all down we all just
destined to
fall I've lost it all the tra by this
town now needless to say kill it with
fire uh the song is bad and Bland and
creepily lifeless it's also quite
ominous ai's idea of a fun pop ballad is
a lamentation about the pointlessness
and futility of existence followed by a
call for us to tear it all down so the
robots are once again not trying to hide
their disdain for the human species
but then again you could point out the
mainstream music industry also hates the
human species and also has been for
decades churning out its own bad and
Bland and creepily lifeless content now
to be fair fortunately I should note
that on social media a lot of people
gave negative reviews to that particular
performance but there are plenty of
examples of soulless AI singers that
have gotten a lot of Praise recently
here's um AI Johnny Cash singing a
Taylor Swift song for example this was
was uh everywhere on social media a few
weeks ago and most people loved it
watch Hello I'm not Johnny
Cash so it's going to be
forever or it's going to go down in
flames you can tell me when it's
over if the high was worth the pain got
a long list of EX lovers they'll tell
you I'm insane cuz you know I love the
players and you love the game cuz we're
young and we're
Reckless we'll take this way too far
it'll leave you
breathless or with a nasty scar got a
long list of EX lovers they'll tell you
on
andan but I've got a blank space
baby and I'll write your
name so there it is and that got rave
reviews for the most part people didn't
care that they were hearing the voice of
a dead country music legend singing some
of the most vapid lyrics imaginable they
embraced it in fact there were people
who even said that they preferred that
to Johnny Cash's original
songs and that's why we could be certain
that eventually nearly all of the
content we consume on the internet and
nearly every movie and show we watch and
song we listen to will all be generated
by AI like that's that's where this is
headed the te the technology is getting
more advanced while at the same time the
humans who produce most of this content
are getting dumber and more vacuous so
this is the process where humans and AI
are essentially meeting in the Middle
where the two become
indistinguishable now I don't think that
AI will ever be able to write a book
like the Lord of the Rings or make a
movie like The Godfather or compose an
original song to match Beethoven but
that's not the kind of art that we
consume these days we watch Marvel
movies and we read short blur we read
short blurbs on the internet we listen
to canned pop music and AI will
certainly be able to produce all of that
I mean it already can
almost produce perfect replicas just not
quite and since we as a culture don't
Value Beauty and originality and depth
anymore we will eventually accept the AI
content and we will consume it just as
vigorously because all we want is the
content after all we don't really care
where it comes from or what it is or who
produced it or what produced it this is
what makes AI dangerous not that it will
become sentient and enslave mankind or
whatever but that it will become
indistinguishable from humans because
humans have become indistinguishable
from
it you know it all kind of reminds me of
the last few pages of George Orwell's
book Animal Farm which was obviously
meant to be an allegory about communism
not artificial intelligence still I
think about the very last line where it
says the creatures outside looked from
pig to man and from man to Pig and from
pig to man again but already it was
impossible to say which was which all
you really need to do is replace the
word Pig with AI and you've got a modern
allegory which is incredible if you
think about it because just a few
decades ago it would have been crazy for
sports illustrator to publish computer
generated slop and pass it off as
journalism it wouldn't have worked but
this past year it went on for months and
nobody even noticed until a website
called futurism happened to catch on men
are becoming indistinguishable from p to
use Orwell's phrase and with each
passing day with each refinement to the
algorithm it becomes more and more
difficult to say which is
which if You' like to see what else I
have to say you can access my full show
by going to dailywire.com or by going to
the Matt wall Show Twitter page hope to
see you there godp speed